Sam has been asking us forever yeah to
all get in the metaverse together yeah
so finally for some reason it was Sunday
everyone was like let's do it let's log
on we go to this room it's completely
empty and it's like a hospital then Sam
goes uh Cody I have your test results
here and I'm like oh really he's like
yeah walk around the corner I've written
your diagnosis on the Whiteboard and I
walk around the corner and it says like
small penis itis or something like that
and we're laughing about that just like
[ __ ] being [ __ ] right all of a
sudden this random it's only Us in this
room this random guy pops in and he we
kind of hear him over to the side and
then he comes over he goes Adam and Adam
goes what and he goes it's Brad from
Dropbox his co-worker at drawblocks from
five or six years ago popped into this
room recognized his username and they
launched into like the same [ __ ]
small talk that you have when you see
someone you haven't seen in a long time
and we're over here laughing at small
penis itis and in the background we hear
like so have you been pretty good man
I'm working for Google Now